[Música]
y es que este fin de semana los
musulmanes de todo el mundo le dan la
bienvenida al mes sagrado del ramadán o
omedes del ayuno que constituye uno de
los cinco pilares del islam junto con la
fe la oración la caridad y la
peregrinación esta celebración que marca
el noveno mes en el calendario islámico
recuerda el momento en que según los
creyentes el corán fue revelado al
profeta mahoma pese a ser un tiempo
dedicado a la oración y a la generosidad
es una fiesta que a menudo ha sido
caracterizada por episodios de violencia
especialmente en lugares sensibles como
la llamada ciudad vieja de jerusalén
foco de lugares sagrados para católicos
judíos y musulmanes y hogar del tercer
sitio más importante del islam la
mezquita de al-aqsa este año no es la
excepción y las autoridades de israel
están en alerta máxima ya que desde la
semana pasada una serie de atentados de
ciudadanos árabes han dejado al menos 16
fallecidos vamos al análisis y para ello
está en directo américa el imán y marwan
will el presidente de la comunidad de
musulmana amarilla en argentina
y gracias a ustedes por estar con
nosotros y vamos a empezar con un poco
de contexto sobre la violencia el año
pasado hubo enfrentamientos nocturnos
entre palestinos o policías israelíes y
colonos las amenazas de desplazamiento
de los palestinos en jerusalén este- las
redadas policiales en la mezquita de
al-aqsa y la prohibición de las
reuniones nocturnas en la puerta de
damasco terminaron en una guerra de 11
días entre israel y los militantes de
gas a más de 250 palestinos fallecidos y
más de 13 fallecidos en israel que tan
factible es repetir un episodio tan
violento de este año
estoy totalmente de acuerdo con tu
análisis y creo que mientras que no haya
justicia es difícil establecer la paz
por eso me refiero a ambos lados a dos
partes el islam enseña y prohíbe
categóricamente la matanza o la
violencia contra personas civiles con
sada contra personas inocentes
el coral hasta tal punto que aclara
quién mata a una persona inocente es
como si hubiera matado a toda la
humanidad entonces la verdad que la
matanza de terrorismo contra personas
civiles contra personas inocentes no se
puede justificar en ninguna
circunstancia pero por otro lado
obviamente para establecer para vivir en
armonía en
cierta convivencia pacífica se requiere
un estándar alto de justicia y creo que
en eso todavía falta mucho y también
para las organizaciones
internacionales y tienen su compromiso
con la región dirigir un esfuerzo mayor
para establecer la justicia y así logra
también la paz la convivencia entre los
diferentes pueblos y las diferentes
relaciones
precisamente los temores por la guerra
de 11 días en mayo pasado en casa y los
atentados de los últimos días han
llevado a las autoridades a desplegar
este año 3.000 efectivos adicionales en
la zona de la ciudad vieja tan sensible
y que sin embargo ayuda a administrar
jordania el aumento del pie de fuerza
para usted mantiene la paz o es una
suerte de provocaciones de violencia
no para mí eso va a provocar más
adicciones y va a llevar a otras
lamentablemente por ambos lados
un agravamiento de violencia o de
adicción para mí es clave y creo que eso
también tenemos pautas muy
fundamentales en el corán y para
asegurar la connivencia y la paz entre
dos pueblos en este caso entre los
palestinos y los de felix se requiere la
justicia y la justicia en este sentido
que los parisinos tengan esos mismos
derechos para vivir en dignidad para
vivir con la igualdad en israel y
obviamente por otro lado necesitan bien
hay que condenar lo que la violencia el
terrorismo contra civiles israelí no
sirve a los palestinos todo lo contrario
va a extraer con un efecto peor injusto
los israelís van al poder responder con
incluso más agresión y van a pasar más
muertes y más daño para los civiles
palestinos y poner superior y también
también los líderes palestinos tienen
quienes o tomar una postura firme y
pensar en su pueblo también este sentido
pero para mí clave ese ahora
del mundo la clave la justicia y
finalmente vamos a hablar de otro caso
la magia sofía en estambul las primeras
oraciones se realizan ochenta y ocho
años después de que está allí perdonar
le devolvió el estatus de mezquita en
2020 con una transformación que se frenó
por la pandemia el edificio bizantino de
los años 530 fue primero un templo de
cristiano después volvió a hacer una
mezquita y después fue un museo será
conflictivo su uso este año de regreso a
ser una mezquita porque sigue siendo un
lugar tan polémico
ingeniería eso es como lo religioso sino
que forma una decisión política del
presidente erdogán porque el islam o
para aclarar desde las fuentes del islam
hasta tal punto el islam lo enseña
preservar y respetar a cualquier lugar
de culto sea una iglesia una sinagoga o
un lugar histórico como pone el pasado
un museo
incluso para realizar un musulmán no
necesita necesariamente una mezquita
sino que pueden congregarse en cualquier
lugar
entonces en ese sentido
la decisión en ese sentido no es una
decisión que se basa en las enseñanzas
islámicas tenemos muchos ejemplos de la
historia donde los califas religiosos
las figuras los líderes religiosos justo
preservar una iglesia y no la
convirtieron en un lugar en una mezquita
en ese sentido creo que es algo que es
más regional algo más con un contexto
geopolítico y no tanto algún religioso
como se aclare que no es un concepto
religioso convertir lugares históricos a
otros templos en una mezquita